all right we're good to go everybody so
we're doing something weird all right
here we go this is the first on tim cast
irl they're taking over they're taken to
they're taking are we still on the air
are they already taking they're gonna
steal us in just one second you heard it
here you guys
oh we're still on the air oh snap let me
show you guys what's going on um i think
we're off now we've given them the
strength oh yes we have i gave them
control
all right the suspense was killing me
because i'm like i don't know when
they're actually going to call me in
if you can hear me i don't know what's
going on we're walking through the daily
wires headquarters i got joe biden
behind me and we are making our way
to the backstage live studio with ben
shapiro michael knowles andrew clavin
matt walsh and jeremy boring and uh i
wrote they're going to take over my show
but i want to take over theirs
so we're making our way through the
studio right now i think i can hear
people let's see if we can pull this off
effectively i smell cigars i smell
cigars
coming around the corner i'll be a
little out of breath
fun huh all right here we go the thing
is that you can oh oh hey what is this
hey uh they just let anybody in here oh
my god what's security i thought we had
security in it no no i i beat all of
them
you're gonna hang out with us absolutely
sir hey that's fine oh great and
actually you guys are taking over my
show at the same time
are we live right now we're on we're on
pool's show you are all my guests on tim
cast irl right now wow i couldn't fit
all of your names in the title so i just
went with ben shapiro
that's fair that's the only one that's
going to get you here nice set dude oh
thank you
this is way better
we're in a trailer out in your your your
alley yeah people don't realize that tim
has been broadcasting from our hill all
week from uh from a fifth-wheel trailer
that he converted into a mobile studio
and tonight he's gonna learn how god
feels about it because we have
thunderstorms coming through nashville
in 45 minutes and he'll still be
broadcasting all right
the most dangerous place in america to
be in the welcome really show everybody
thanks for having me absolutely this is
the best lineup of guests i've ever had
on tim cast iron i really like being on
your show from here because when i go on
your show from the hinterland i got to
drive an hour through the woods with
serial killers texas chainsaw it is it
is
it's a cool house your security guy
almost gave me a heart attack as i was
walking out i walk out in the dark of
night and this guy goes hi
well
it's funny when uh we've invited some
left personalities who already have
apprehension
and they're really scared because
you know we're in it's western maryland
but it's the middle of nowhere it's like
the blue ridge mountains yeah and you
drive
through pitch black and then you have to
drive up a long it's about you know what
like 1500 feet driveway and there are
security deer everywhere
they're ready to pounce well you know
when you're driving up in the in the
dead of night and your lights are on all
of a sudden you see glowing eyes
everywhere
and then you're like
i think most people are fine with it in
the summer it's fine it's still day out
when you arrive it's true what were you
guys talking about before i interrupted
we were talking about 2024 and and what
we think is going to happen and we're
sort of positing the thesis that
democrats are so wildly out of tune with
the american public right now that
republicans look pretty good but they
could make the mistake of taking their
eye off the ball which brought up the
inevitable t ward right of course which
is which is trump and whether he runs oh
yeah yeah i think so but isn't it
starting to feel like desantis might be
your mouth to god's ears my friend
i will say that trump saying
i think just this last week that his
health would be a factor in making the
decision uh is the first time that he
said anything that in any way left him
an out not to run yeah
and in many ways you know
he has a lot to lose i agree if he runs
if he there's always going to be an
asterisk beside his 2020 loss
if he were to run and lose in 2024 you
remove the asterisk and so and all the
all the prosecutions that they're
threatening with is clearly political
now that makes me want him to run like
keep playing keep playing dirty no i
don't think so because i think that he
could actually be hurt financially uh by
those if he runs if he doesn't run they
won't i have this sense everybody keeps
telling me i'm wrong everybody who knows
trump tells me i'm wrong i just sense
he's not going to run that he's staying
relevant he's raising money off his you
know the
hints that he's going to run but i just
don't think there's enough in it for him
and he's old well i always like to tell
you you're wrong no no to your point
drew that the prosecutions could hurt
him that this is the problem that the
powers that be are powerful yes
they can actually wield that power and
really hurt you but
why is desantis not in the same vain as
trump well he he doesn't run if trump
runs i think i i think you know i'm
beginning to death that's true really
that's true and the reason that i'm
beginning to doubt that's true is
because i think that what desantis like
most good politicians understand is
there is a time yeah right this is
something that jeremy i've discussed a
bunch of times before uh which is that
there are certain politicians where it's
like if they had grabbed the moment it
would have been their moment and if they
missed the moment they're toast and this
happened with for example elizabeth
warren in 2016. if she had jumped in in
2016 and not let hillary clinton
foreclose her she would have been the
bernie figure in that race and she would
have stolen a lot of thunder from
hillary clinton being the first
presidential woman nominee chris
christie in 2012. right chris christie
is pointing like there are certain
periods where if you take if you go for
the brass ring and you grab at it it's
your moment and then if you miss it it's
just and also also the other thing is i
think it affairs desantis understands
that the
in in the primary 2016
republicans running against trump they
either just ignored him and didn't
attack him at all which was a mistake or
they attacked him basically from the
left and they they said that well i
don't like his attitude it makes me
uncomfortable
i i think trump is vulnerable and what
desantis probably understands although i
don't know him is that if you you can go
at trump from the right and you can say
you can hit trump on vaccines you could
hit him on fouch you could have one
covid um and i i think i actually think
the best path for desantis
as you said we're still
two years away from this
but if desantis were to choose to
challenge trump i actually think his
best path is not to hit trump i think
his best path is essentially to say
mr president i voted for you
there's no question in my mind that
you're the man we needed in 2016. the
question is are you the man that we need
into trump's not going to allow that
right that's what they tried in 2016 and
then eventually trump will turn around
and go after your wife and you're you're
right you're just sitting there you're
not prepared for it so i think you have
to be
more proactive it just you don't have to
be obsessive about it but you might i
agree with you from the right i agree
with you that a lot of trump's appeal in
2016 because i felt this way when he was
debating jeb bush is that he just kept
pummeling the guy who was more to the
center and jeb bush should be like i'm
really uncomfortable with how you talk
about illegal immigration and trump
you're stupid like yeah
and then there's a lot of that i have
i feel like i have a different
perspective from you guys because uh for
one look i'm dressed compared to you
guys
i do think you know in all honesty
though i come from kind of a different
world i grew up in chicago and i didn't
vote for trump in 2016. i don't think
everybody here did did you guys no i
didn't i did i'd never either uh in 2020
i i've just been seeing over the past
decade what i would describe as the left
being so unreasonable and just out of
their minds i'm sitting with a group of
prominent conservatives and i've
this is not how i grew up
i grew up in chicago surrounded by
democrats and now i'm looking at 2024
and i would i'm like i would vote for
desantis i i don't know i don't i didn't
like trump in 2016. i voted for him
because i know biden because i knew the
the obama you voted for him in 2020 2020
sorry yeah 2020 i voted for trump uh i
liked that he didn't start new wars i
liked the abraham accords i liked school
choice and i did not like wokeness
because i think it's an affront to all
of the civil rights battles that have
been fought
now we see desantis in florida and
everything he's doing speaks to me not
everything but a lot of it so i don't
know if i would vote for trump i didn't
necessarily want to vote for him in the
first place
this is i think the biggest issue for
trump and that is that my theory of
elections is that elections are
oppositional and whoever the election is
a referendum on loses so in 2016 the
great myth that the media tried to
create is that it was a referendum on
trump and it was not a referendum on
trump it was a referendum on hillary
clinton people looked at hillary and
they're like i hate that lady she's
awful she's garbage and i don't know
this trump guy he's real weird he says
dumb stuff but i'll take a shot out
that's right this is how trump can get
fewer votes in wisconsin
than did mitt romney
that's right and still win wisconsin
correct because ever because the
election was really about hillary right
democrats were like yeah and then by
2020 joe biden ran what for him was i
think the only campaign you could run
but it turned out to be kind of a
brilliant campaign which is he just lay
in a basement for for six months and joe
and every so often they'd creak open the
crypt and
walk out and say
and then he'd go back downstairs and
that would be the end of his campaign
and so the referendum was not on biden
the referendum was on trump if you go to
2024 if trump runs again the question is
i'm not sure that's a referendum is it
on biden or is it on trump right that's
a real question because we they're now
really really prominent figures if it's
anybody
anybody but trump it's hartford not to
be a referendum by him he's been
president for the last four years and
he's done i i i'm honest to god i'm
amazed he's been able to set this many
things on fire for a man who's not
ambulatory
you know there's a tactic desantis is
using a rhetorical tactic that i think
every republican needs to adopt the old
republican view of things when they were
asked a question what do you want for
breakfast in the morning let's say hey
senator rand paul what do you want for
breakfast you'd say well you know some
people want omelets and some people want
pancakes and the great thing about
america is we can have whatever we want
for breakfast right it's very sort of
ambiguous thing and you ask desantis
what do you want for breakfast he goes
look we tried pancakes in arkansas and
we tried
omelets and we're going to have
scrambled eggs scrambled eggs work in
florida and they're going to work
throughout america okay and there's no
question or ambiguity that's very
persuasive well let me ask you is joe
biden even going to run in 2024 i mean i
think they have to i think they have to
strap him to a gurney they have to turn
them upright and they have to just
they have to what are they going to do
they're going to try out kamala harris
the worst candidate who's ever been
created by god or man it's unbelievable
you will not be able to speak at all so
it doesn't matter
what are you going to do kamala harris
is the best description i've heard is
from the account jt lol which is that
she is the human embodiment of a
predictive text program you start
typing words into google and whatever is
the next word is what she says and so
the importance of the passage of time is
important with regard to the passage of
time and like so she's terrible and then
then they're like oh well you know we've
got this other guy over here and he's so
great that he went on paternity leave
for two months and nobody even noticed
he couldn't fill a pothole in south bend
but on the other hand he is gay yeah and
and that's that's literally the pitch
for steve
that's an impact
first of all commit i like that camilla
harrison to me she's always like um
like i was in in high school when i have
to give a a book report but i didn't
read the book like that's what she
always sounds like but i i that you just
you run into just a a simple fact of age
so are you going to run a guy who will
be what he'll be 82 right
and so by the end of his term he's 86.
that's just like an impossible they
don't have to get him to the end of his
term they just have to get him to yeah i
don't know but for the purpose of the
purpose of running they have to pretend
that he's gonna make it to the other
side yeah i don't think no he didn't
pretend he's gonna make it to the end of
the term this time right he basically
the problem that they have the reason i
think they have to run him and i think
that
the base doesn't care
if he's still cogent no the base doesn't
care they don't care the reason they
have to run him is kamala they would
like to sub him out with footage
they might even like to sub him out if
if we are making moves towards trump
with uh with hillary clinton which would
be their great revenge fantasy playing
out
but
the problem is that there is a sitting
vice president
and how do you get her to just
move aside and let you do that well but
the only way is it they do have one
trump card right which is that they
could they could theoretically call
michelle
right that is that is clearly their best
move if that is because because she that
is a black woman vp you should say
listen there's this other black woman
and she's more famous than you and she's
more popular than you and she's a
best-selling author and we have now
softened her image to the point where
she's not the the radical who is writing
princeton these are how americans racism
uh everybody wants to be president right
she might not be she likes being oprah
she likes being very very popular oprah
wants to be president oprah would that's
a better everyone wants to be president
listen michelle obama is the is the
nuclear
option no question no question why
wouldn't the user
i think they would love to use her i
think the only question is whether she
and barack want to have his like if she
were to run and lose whether this would
tarnish the obama magisterial image that
he's created for himself and that guy
loves him i mean obama loves him from
obama i mean when he came to the white
house that that was it's one of the
sorriest places
it really was it was the first time
it actually did i i can't believe it
says it made me feel bad for for biden
it did oh i mean i i i like like he he
walks up on stage and he makes a joke
about how he's barack obama's vice
president and then barack obama was like
well yeah over there was my vice
president you don't get to make that
joke that makes you a dick
the two things that were most that were
most on display in that entire episode
were one what a sorry
bastard barack obama is and if you read
maureen dowd during his administration
she hated him for his treatment of joe
biden as his vice president biden was
this completely loyal subservient even
vice president
and obama treated him like absolute dirt
the entire time
so you see you just see how
his view of himself and his view of
people around him and then the other
sorry thing is you saw the media's view
of him you know that that horrible clip
where biden realizes that the president
of the united no one wants to talk to
the president of the united states
they're because they're all talking to
barack obama he's got his hand on
obama's shoulder and obama's shaking him
off to shake hands over here just
realize
the meaning of he wants somebody to
guide him to the bathroom that's right
the media genuinely believes that barack
obama is a deity and barack obama agrees
with them that's that's what was on
display to me joe rogan say something
that effect about uh michelle obama and
uh i don't want to put words in joe's
mouth but he mentioned something about
brocamol being a great president or
something that effect and michelle obama
being a potentially great option i think
i think you know he's relevant for one
having the biggest podcast in the world
but i think he speaks to a lot of people
who are in the middle and confused or
don't necessarily know how they're gonna
uh
vote come 2020 uh 2022 and 2024 but i
think if these people
moderate independence former left people
see michelle obama i think a lot of them
will be convinced
to vote democrat again
i'm not entirely convinced for me my
brain exploded after 2020 with just yeah
i'm done with this you know uh or 20
2018 even when i think it was 31 seats
that did
districts that voted for trump
vote democrat and all of these moderate
democrats said we're going to bring you
kitchen table issues we're not going to
focus on culture war issues and the
first thing they do is they move to
impeach trump and it felt like i was
just spit on i was like you know i had
faith that if i if i just you know push
back i donated to a lot some of these
democrats thinking that they'll actually
re you know reconfigure things and fix
this and they only made it worse the
only the only thing i think that they
could really harm michelle obama if she
were to run is i think that she really
has ideologically she always has been
very radical and i think that she will
re-embrace wokeness because she too is
in that bubble i think the most
ironically the thing that we complain
the most about is probably the thing
that may save the republic and that is
the media bias the media bias is so
strong that democrats do not understand
that there's an entire world outside of
the beltway that just thinks they're
crazy and so the reason that you see the
white house saying things like well you
know it's very important that we use the
doj to crack down on people stopping
little girls from being turned into
little boys the reason they say that is
because the new york times agrees with
them and the washington post agrees with
them and everybody they know agrees with
them the other thing about michelle
obama is that she's attractive to people
i guess not to me but the people as like
an idea but if she's running for office
then she's actually have to be out there
talking when you listen to her talk kind
of to your point about how radical [ __ ]
but also she's just really a kind of a
vile human being i'll never forget this
story she told on a podcast somewhere
about when she experienced
racism like she was still harboring this
resentment because she went to get ice
cream and a white woman
didn't notice her and like and cut in
front of her and she told this whole
story about how she was a victim of
racism as the first lady united states
uh because a white woman was getting ice
cream before herself there's that story
that she told about how she went to the
grocery store and she was tall so
somebody asked her to take something
down from the top exactly that she said
that that was racism it's like no you're
just tall i mean
i might ask matt to get something from
the top shelf for me
who who are the voters who fall for that
stuff yeah
are there i agree with you tim you know
i think that she's i think michelle
obama i don't think she would run but i
think that she is a good candidate if
she runs but you know the voters are not
as uh enamored of identity politics as
the democrats are they're in no way are
they well the the the poll about the
parental rights and education bill in
florida has overwhelming support from
democrat voters right who were pulled at
the very least yet they doubled down on
this stuff it's like you were saying
that the media bias is palpable i don't
know if you guys saw cnn plus only has
10 000 daily active users wow
you know
hold on just a second yeah
but i think i enjoy chris
wallace's new show what have i done i
think
by the way who who was the business
genius at warner who was like okay so we
have cnn and no one watching
what if we take the same post and we put
them behind a paywall
doing more boring things
i mean how does this go wrong here guys
well this seems like a genius business
plan to me well there's people investing
every time you don't watch cnn no make
money i like it i will tell you guys
something interesting though because uh
matt and i were talking about this the
other day when i asked you why is it the
daily wires 600 000 plus subscribers cnn
can't even get 10 000 daily users you
mentioned mission i think is what you
said right
when i worked i said me i said the
reason is me and then
the number two reason he did say that he
said he was better than everybody uh
you know in in uh when i was working for
these big corporate media outlets i was
at a company called fusion which is abc
news and univision
they said mission-driven storytelling
that was that was their line as to what
their goals were it's almost like they
were either predicting or wanting
politics to be the main driver of what
was going to bring people to different
media outlets the only issue is i felt
like their narratives were built on lies
and manipulation we have to withhold
information from people trick them
feed them only the information we want
whereas i feel like with what you guys
do with what we do it's here's
everything let's argue about it yep well
that's that's what i love about this
show that we get to do once a month is
that we quite often disagree and those
disagreements i think are central to to
what makes the daily wire work i think
at the core of the daily wire success is
our fundamental religious difference
that we talked about it today in fact
that our fundamental religious
disagreement
means that central to our friendship is
the idea that there's not ubiquity and
that there's not uh
unanimity in our thought and that's it's
not that we don't have a strong
perspective as a company it's not that
we don't have a strong that we don't
have a side in the fight but it's that
we that we are actually engaged in the
exchange of ideas and trying to always
learn more and and know more and be
better tim thank you for uh well for
coming on uninvited please feel free to
invite yourself on the show again in the
future
thank you to all of our dailywire.com
members for making this possible we're
going to wrap up because there's a
thunderstorm rolling in this guy's got
to get back to his tornado bait trailer
and ben shapiro has to get on an
airplane and get out of here head over
to dailywire.com subscribe use promo
code build the future you still have 23
hours left to become a member at 45
off we'd really appreciate you being a
member we appreciate our members making
it possible for us to do the work we're
doing including fighting woke disney so
thanks again we'll see you next week
we'll give you a fake laugh i don't know
one of these days
should i just run out the door now yeah
you shouldn't leave
thanks guys
thank you thanks for having me they're
in the earlier show earlier part of the
show they were talking about uh trump
desantis and who was gonna run and then
they got they kind of parlayed the
conversation into the democrats and who
they thought was going to run for the
democrats i thought that ben shapiro
made a very interesting point about um
populism when he mentioned michelle
obama and running a populist candidate
i'm interested to see what you guys
think about that
the michelle obama
question that part of the discussion is
what fascinated me because
i i i do think she would probably be the
best candidate for the democrats i do
think again
corporate media is obsessed with oh
so-and-so's making history because
they're the first
black woman this just like we just saw
with kidanji brown jackson
and so
people love they're fascinated by
participating or witnessing history and
it's like and again it's like when
barack obama first ran in 2008 i think a
lot of people voted because this is a
history-making deal and i want to be on
the record that i voted for barack obama
and it's proof that i'm not racist yes
it's got the history building and
they've they've spent a lot of years
curating michelle obama's image
and having the last name obama is just
going to be huge in the realm of
politics so yeah she is the nuclear
option for sure uh we we parlayed what
you guys were talking about with
populism and i liked how ben brought up
michelle obama i think we may have had
an audio technical glitch in the first
part and then we it seemed to smooth
that worked yeah you guys got it the
first time you know and it's all about
it when you have a new piece of
technology a new cool idea you try it
and if it fails you try it again and you
do it and then you get it right and
that's what we're doing
they look great through the rain yeah
you're kind of damp now
and uh hang out those guys cigar smoke
everywhere oh gosh
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you